congrats are in order for prince harry
and meghan markle
the couple has welcomed baby number two
a girl
[Music]
[Applause]
they are already parents to two-year-old
son archie whom they welcomed in may
2019.
we're just so thrilled to have our own
little bundle of joy
the duke and duchess of sussex announced
they were expecting on valentine's day
with a beautiful black and white photo
showing off meg's growing baby bunk i
think that picture
sums up not only the joy between this
couple who are expecting their second
baby but
a sense of lightness a sense of relief
it's such a relaxed picture it's such an
unusual
um picture for a royal pregnancy
announcement
and i think that's largely because it is
just so relaxed and laid back they look
completely
happy in their back garden at the time a
rep for the happy pair
shared a statement saying quote we can
confirm that archie is going to be a big
brother
the duke and duchess of sussex are
overjoyed to be expecting their second
child
i am very excited about that yeah during
their prime time special with oprah
winfrey harry and megan shared the
gender
and revealed the duchess was due in the
summer when oprah asked how they feel
about baby number two
harry gushed amazing just grateful just
to have any child
anyone or any two would have been
amazing but to have a boy and then a
girl
what more could you ask for the couple
also announced in the interview that
they were done having kids
saying too is it the exciting news comes
after megan revealed in november that
she tragically suffered a miscarriage in
july
in an op-ed for the new york times the
39-year-old duchess says
losing a child means carrying an almost
unbearable grief
the suit star said she experienced her
loss one morning while holding baby
archie
quote after changing his diaper i felt a
sharp cramp
i dropped to the floor with him in my
arms something was not right
i knew as i clutched my firstborn that i
was losing my second
meg details how harry helped her writing
i lay in a hospital bed holding my
husband's hand
i kissed his knuckles wet from both our
tears
i tried to imagine how we'd heal she
said she watched her husband's
heartbreak as he tried to hold the
shattered pieces
of mine in january et spoke with royal
expert katie nichol
about the possibility of megan and harry
having a second child
it's clearly the case that harry and
megan would love
a sibling for archie and you know
megan wrote very bravely about the
miscarriage that they suffered
in the summer so we know that they were
trying
um for a second baby and you know i'm
sure they're hoping very much that this
will be the year
when auntie gets to have a little
brother or a little sister
oh and it was the year it's a feeling of
joy
and we already know megan and harry's
daughter is going to be a powerhouse
in may the parents of two served as the
co-chairs for global citizens vax life
concert benefit event
and during the event the duchess opened
up about their daughter-to-be at the
time and how she's inspiring her
to empower women around the world when
we think of her
we think of all the young women and
girls around the globe who must be given
the ability and support
to lead us forward congrats to megan and
harry
on their new bundle of joy